these capsules we will see the proof by
resolution
so we finally saw the three tools
which we needed to know the
substitution the unification then the
transformation into normal form
conjunctive to finally see a
commented what we can do a
proof by resolution then a proof
by resolution will proceed as follows
so let's imagine that from a formula
or a set of formula f1 in
want to show that these formulas
implies another formula f all this
we will do in advance and we will
transform our rooney our or our
formulas f1 into a set of clauses
in the form of nice amendments then of
that we will add the negation of f2 that
will convert in normal form
conjunctive also we will add that
in our club center so in fact
it's a bit like doing a
evidence by contradictions where we assume
the negation of what we are trying to
contrary to what we are trying to prove
we will know if we do not arrive
contradiction in the proof not
resolution the contradiction is going
correspond to the deliberation of a
empty clause and it's claude dilain on
wants to get it by applying so
repetitive at what is called the rule
of resolutions that we want to see in his
instinct and so what are we going to do this
that we will take our clauses in our
knowledge base we are going to have
added the negation of what we are trying
to prove
and here we will apply the judgment of
resolution by taking fathers from
clauses by getting new clauses
we add to our set our base
of knowledge and we will do this
until we get to what we're going
call the clause quickly I'm counting
will describe in a moment and we do
this until that's so if we
happens to demonstrate the empty lacrosse it's
that it has been shown that f1 implies f2 and
then if we come to a moment when finally
we are no longer able to apply a
new way of solving rule
to generate new clauses but
in this case in f1 m
the icp to f2 so what is this rule
of resolution goodbye two cases the
first case this is the case we call
propositional so it's some
thing I did not come to talk about but
the propositional logic is in
makes a special case the logic of
first order is the logic of
first year where the predicates do not
take no arguments of which crap
then in fact it's basically a
cock in the near body or yop to
two variables the logic of first
order but without quantified variable 14
so the resolution rule in the kop
propositional goes as follows imagine
that I have two clauses that we will call
clauses per year the first klaus and
the addition of and clothes p1 until
pn and then the second klaus and
the addition of the clauses of mclaude q1
up to qm
as well as the assistant there with in addition
the addition with the negation of peace in
p1 who has it literally first of my
first clause is the rue de la
resolution says that I can take these
two clauses here here and the from
expands generating a clause that is going
call a clause resolving you who is going
to contain p2 until peace is only a
until you like it so that's going to be the
disjunction of all of these literal
so has all the other theroux who
involves pop and finally offered to
morocco we will find the rule modus
we have seen previously in a
other capsule because we can take
so cursed though said let's lose f1
implies f2 and f2 can be combined
together as claude barral for
get like no forgiveness proof of f1
so f1 involved two and f1 can be
combined together to get the butt
sales halls f2 so if these words
available it is we have seen
previously pointed out that f
involved two in normal form
connective c
the negation of f1 or f2 but if we
rent ff since we have f 1
finally we see that we are the negation of
f1 then f1 so we can get like
close solving all the others
coasts in my my first clause
here my second here my other words c
montayral cf2 here I have no other
so what I get is well and truly
f2 so me having already made a case
particular of the queen of resolution
in the propositional kop and
now we are ready to move to
resolution rule but when we have
more general predicates with
variables so clauses that were
obtained from logic formulas of
first order with magic no one has
two clauses compares then combined
so a cause first clause she
contains the predicates l1 to l
aisne then a clause m that counted
as predicted that m
1 until mn so now let's imagine
Also, I can find myself
literal is so the case of the father who
is part of then until the groin one
other literal m
helm which is part of the m1 up
same who are such that I can
find a teta unifier or a
substitution does so between unifying
between them what is the negation of m
so a head-to-tail substitution if I
payroll applies is it case where is the
negation of mails I get the same
thing so can I am able
to unify lk and the negation of mm so
if I am able to find a pair
like that but I can get the
closerie jauldes sale from the east
of m
which will match one more time two
parts first is l1 up to l
groin but without alcohol
so they have up to the horizon
and then she as more healthy
to the groin so that's my first
part my second part that goes
invoke m
1 to mn but 100 m
so she m1 up to m / m -1 and then 1 is
the most unfair knn pardon m
mb yes and so kind a new clause
who will be the disjunction of all and
liteo there but it's going to be the breeding ground where
I will apply to each of his
lateral mass substitution gold in
did my clause that counted all that is
she and all and m
I'm going to apply the substitution to
this clause so I'm going to apply the
solution to each each of the littorals
so that's the rule the definition of
the general rule to get from
of two clauses a clause solving you
we look at example if I have two
parent clauses she who would be the
negation of mourning x or animal x that a
other transparent that would be a big
arm that would even I call m which
is the negation of Greek animal or dy
so in the intention that had in
rise it would be she a ca would l2 that
it would be m 1
it would be a lot like a clause
solving that I can get from
of that these masks x or size x and that
it's because I notice it's the
drug negation
x ah no sorry i the animal g x here and
I have the animal negation and pure play
unified animal x with the negation of the
negation of an animal and therefore animal y I
can unify them using the upg y
equal x so I just want to take it there
replace by x I get on the
negation of an animal y then I apply
parents the denial of negation of a
animal is there that I apply suspicion
there is gallix I really get a
animal x and so that means that I
can take the other coasts so
in this case l1 and mm
put them in my clause solving then
apply my ip so i have to
replace y with x
so die y among others will become taïx
in my clause resolving then the
drug negation and that transpires
an allegation of doc and so this is a
reservation clause that I can get a
combine l & m here in my example
notice that two parent clauses
may have multiple clauses
solving according to the choice of my
literal she copy m
it happened sometimes two from the
same pair of klose parents to get
more of a sales clause then the
resolution rule as it is
described until now is correct
so we always get expressions
which are logically drift abl of our
knowledge base but finally is
not complete
some clauses that would not happen
to prove and against to get a
resolution rule or proof of
resolution that completes
we have to get what we call
must use factorization the
factoring that corresponds to learning
so if we have two lives potting that in
the same klose have an ip a rpg so we
is capable of a bride in bars
of the opg do a factorization that's
actually replaced literal apart from the
result of their unification
so we're a factor that's the result
of this transformation there then see
for example if I have my closed the clause
next so that of z or p2 x or pdf of
there
well in fact i can get like
factor that second country of f2i is
noticed that I am able to unify p
2 x with pdf of y to a substitute for
experts fbi y so would have happened to
me to take this clause lopy of
generate a new clause that will be a
factor that's called a factor that
would be that aids or pdf of it is
so to get a rule of
resolution that
complete and be able to prove
all that is logically shores
from my knowledge base
I have to allow myself to do
this update the needs is either
before or after applying the rule
resolution to generate
new clauses
so that's more in my research
when I combine I make the choice of
claude that I combine years said of
resolutions can give new
clauses to eventually arrive at the
the plain clause of the empty clause but in
more of that I can do some
factorization to the needs from a
clause to get his factor that has
added based on knowledge you
see example start with a
example imagine that I have the fact that
all dogs are animals to
first-order logic we could
first rank after a crisis like for
any geek this jogging get involved animal
x also imagine that I have that all
animals will die so for all there
animal implies to go there a logical
of the first role but I also note
that I come to fido who so is a
dog with the logic of first hours
recreation like the price of the dog code
and fido but your house that I want and
prove that fido are going to die
eventually and so to do that I
have to prove that die fido and
deliverables from my three daughters
to the first order logic that I have
right here
so to make his family's formula
my knowledge base here I take
the denial of what I'm trying to
prove to know that the negation that
fido will die so the denial of david
o I put fire in normal shape
connective so with a little practice
we quickly see then that all these
formulas also can translate into
form in my conjunctiva under this
form there so I leave myself as
exercise do it from everyone and we're going
start our proof by resolution in
combining departure of Klose together for
try to come to clause 8
first thing I could do
it's taking clause 1 and 2 here and
here is applied the rule of resolution
using the upg and that's gary gray
so actually I have in an animal
xj6 the negation of mid-animal friends
I can resume the negation of his
and combine it with animal x unify it
with the Greek upg requirement so I get
as close before the denial of
john y or day y so its dogmas there because
that I take x more load by y
exfo was substituted by y is i have a
fifth clause in my base of
knowledge that I can combine with
cats here to bring me closer to their
empty clauses to this is precisely I can
take my clause my new clause has
combine it with clause 3 by doing
unification also like that because
that in 3 g fido dogts that I can
unified with negation of negation
of 2 gears is that when changing Greek
by fido actually these charges there by
fido I stop unfaithful mastiffs if I'll have
two negations that would give me mastiffs
fido that would be unified with videos
here is what's left is dailly
Greek where I apply the substitution y
equal fido devotes daifi water and
finally I could combine 6 with 4
then apply the rule resolution i
now scoci i have exactly
so I have negation of die fido that I
can confirm that I can combine with
die fido with the arrival of resolution
since I am doing the negation of die fido
I get in the videos here
there is more a4 and a6 pardon
of literals a4 and a6 so the clause
resulting
this is the empty set and so I
well and truly demonstrated that especially the
the empty clause that die fido and is
derived abl logically from
September there so I demonstrated that fido
are going to die are an example can more
complete it's once again our
example based on rome so here we want
demonstrate that marcus to Caesar the first
what we do is we take
all of our facts they've filed down
conjunctive format we did it
previously no I will not do them here I
just want to show
oh no sorry when just done
here is taking the whole different
natural language for omitted a logical
first order and the logic of the
first order also proved that
marcus to seize it is proved the
predicate hai marcus 16 years so when
I did here is that I passed
directly to the normal form
connective that has been demonstrated in a
previous capsule
and when one has to do is add
the clauses of the negation of
the approved expression namely to ymare
that Caesar so I add his negation
ie the negation of highmark 16
years and negation of mercus lines Caesar
in close normal conjunctive it is
exactly the same thing so we are
singer not too much work to do
then the rest of the clauses here is the
clauses in conjunctive normal form the
derivative contract and previously
so let's do another meal resolution
so first thing we could
do is take 2 and 3 and help
the handsets in sum with the rule of
resolution we see that with the upg etc
without equal marcus we are able
to unify to unify pump and a marcus
with the negation of the negation of
pumping an accent that gives us the
time closery that only contains
Roman ex years to which we apply our
substitution etc are equal marcus so
it gives roman marcus
then from that I can take 10 and then the
combined with 6 so I notice jérôme
and marcus here then in 6 jerome an ex
cat with a negation the front so I
should be able to get it there
Just that juni firmin ex cat with
roman marcus not replaced x4 by
marcus and so I can add the clause
which contains the other coasts of the
clause 6g no doubt the summer road to the
clause say so that's only the
potting soil of croatia what will do
part of the clause results so I
the loyal obtains marcus caesar or hi hi
Marcus Caesar and that's because and what
cap once again the result clause
must replace by marcus because of my
super g here allowed me to apply husband
of resolution I could take 11 and
combined with nine we notice in nine
I also got fed up that Caesar I'm going
no need to do substitution
allows me to get loyal marxisant on
the self I can take 12
combined with 7 12 which my new clause
that I can combine with this here
actually I notice a loyal here
with a negation forward so in
charge in substance bloodless by marcus
then exercise by Caesar I am able
to obtain as resulting close
the set of other literals here in
this house where I replace bloodless by
marcus and ixis by Caesar so it's me
gives negation people marcus or a
negation caesar leaders or a
negation of murder marcus season
then I can take 13 and then combined
with 8 so in eight days mark that
I murdered ancient Caesar marcus and
here I have the negation of murder marcus
16 years old I can apply
stopping the resolutions I have not
will substitute negation of
marcus or negation leaders 16 years by
a negation people marcus negation
Caesar leaders
then of self I can take my
new clause 14 combine it with 4.4
ranking leaders Caesar I have soul
denial of Caesar people so I get
as close resulting negation people
marcus and finally negation people
Marcus I can combine that with worried
people marcuse to finally get the
empty clause
so i have to demonstrate that marcus to y
grab
in addition to proving that f2 is
a logical consequence of a set of
tf1 formulas
we can also exploit the trace of
evidence process to find this is
what values ​​of variables that me
allow to deduce f2 from f1
is what we actually do that's all
to simply wave a predicate that we're going
that we decided to call rep for
response with the variables that are
involved in the clauses of the
denial of f2 and we have more than the
evidence
then we apply the evidence by
resolution that one stops when one has a
clause that rather than obvious contains
only the predicate or the literal
dir
so let's see an example again
with our example of Rome so
imagine that if we want to know
who is here in gold in this case if
our ninth clause that we have here
will add we said it's true like
follows the lacrosse one would like to prove in
is that there is an x ​​such that at
ix of Caesar is true his negation so we
must introduce the negation of the
denial of existence
exciser hays it's for all x the
negation of surpluses after that
after ardizas sion so after having
put this conjunctive format what we
would get it's the negation of hays
etc. this season and finally we're going
add
in the clause we will add
response with the variables that is found
in the clause when 6th only
accept and so we did
except negation of hai exceeds 6 years or
answer except so now we're going
to prove by resolution
from this set of clauses there
so I'm going to go a little bit more
quickly since the proof is felt
I can combine two with 3 for
get roman marcus again I
can combine 10 with six to get
loyal marcus Caesar or haï mercus 16 years
I can combine an eleven with 9 for
get loyal marcus caesar or answer
marcus so noticed that now
by combining with nine games comes
to introduce in my proof the predicate
answer with x 7 x is here was was
substituted by marcus so we see that at
the end we'll know that the hic this
that allowed me to unify the hated the
Russia it was the value of x so me
allowing a unification it was
marcus here we will drag that until the
end of proof
so from 12 if I combine with
sep i can get the clause here very
little to combine with 8 to get a
new clause that I can combine
with 4 to hold a clause a little more
short and finally that I can
combine with one to get a clause
which only contains the so-called core price
answer is my proof is over so
I have shown that someone who is
Caesar and this person is marcus